As before, you'll create a new
application with a blank activity.
Android Studio will take you to the
activity designer, and as you can see,
here, it's populated with a very
basic hello world text field.
I'm going to paste it in the UI
declaration for the activity recognition
app, and you'll see the code for this in
the instructor notes below the video.
So, I'll just replace all
of this with my code.
And my code, as you saw,
had the two buttons for
requesting activity updates and
for removing activity updates.
And then this text view, which just
had the details of the activities.
Now you'll see that
there are some errors.
This is because I don't
have any strings set up.
These are values that you
specify using XML files,
keeping them separate
from the UI declaration.
This is good practice.
To this point in the course,
I've been hard coding them, but
that's not a best practice.
I'm not going to go into
detail on explaining them now.
Check out the Android fundamentals
courses, or the documentation for
how they work.
It's pretty straightforward and
once you've done it a few times,
it becomes second nature.
I'm just going to paste
in these string values.
And you can get the code
from the instructor notes.
Strings are in res >
values > strings.xml.
You can see there isn't much in here.
And I'm going to paste the new stuff in.
So now I've pasted in all the different
string resources that I'm going to be
using in this application.
And if I go back to my layout file,
we'll see that the red has gone away,
that those errors are now fixed.
Next, as you've done before,
you'll need to update your build.gradle
to use the services libraries.
Build.gradle can be found in your
gradle scripts, and that's the one for
the module app.
And you can see it here.
I'm just going to paste it
in my Play services version.
Do remember that when you're building
this to check the version of
the library.
I'm just using 6.5.+ here.
If you have a later version
of the library, use that, and
also try to use the specific latest
version of the library you have on your
machine as we demonstrated earlier.
For the purpose of keeping things
simple, I'm putting the plus in here,
but that's bad practice.
Also, the name may change.
Just look out in the documentation.
At the moment its called
com.google.android.gns:play-services,
but this name may change over time,
so just keep an eye out for that.
Once you're done with that, you also
need to update the app manifest.
The first thing your going to add to the
app manifest are details on the services
libraries that you're going to use.
You enter these just above
the closing application tag and
I'm just going to paste mine in.
You see right now it has red indicating
an error, but when I do my next grade,
I think that'll go away.
You don't need to worry about that.
And the final thing that you
have to add to your app manifest
is the ability to use
the activity recognition APIs.
And you do this with
a user's permission tag.
So, I'm just going to go to
underneath my application tag, and
I'll paste in the user's permission.
So you can see, I'm just setting
it to user's permission.
And the Android name is
the activity recognition details.
So now my manifest is set up,
my build.gradle is set up.
So I've done everything I need for
my project to work for
activity recognition.
So now all we have to do is
actually write the project.